The News Gazette in Illinois says the
man accused of kidnapping a Chinese
exchange student attended an event last
week to honor her a photo from the event
appears to show
Brent Christensen with an unknown woman
he's due to appear in court today in
connection with the disappearance of
ying-ying Zhang she was a researcher at
the University of Illinois where
Christensen got a master's degree in May
Tony de copal shows us the disturbing
events that led to Christensen's arrest
Tony good morning good morning when
investigators reviewed the search
history on Brent Christensen's phone it
showed he'd visited a website focused on
abduction according to a criminal
complaint Zhang was on her way to meet a
new landlord when Christensen allegedly
approached her investigators do not
believe she's still alive
surveillance video allegedly shows the
moment Brent Christensen pulls over to
talk the ying-yang Jang
a minute later Jang gets into
Christensen's black Saturn and they
drive away the 26 year old University of
Illinois student was wearing a grey and
pink flannel shirt and carrying a blue
backpack at 1:35 p.m. on June 9th Zhuang
boarded a bus near campus and texted her
new building manager to say she was
running late at 1:52 p.m. Jang got off a
bus and tried to flag down another nine
minutes later she encountered
Christensen at 238 the building manager
texted Jang and got no response
University staff reported the exchange
student missing that night police
determined the sunroof and cracked
hubcap on the car in the surveillance
video matched Christian since 2008
Saturn I am shocked Lance Cooper was
Christensen's former academic advisor in
the physics graduate program at the
University of Illinois there was nothing
unusual about him he was a bit quiet but
he interacted well with the students he
was a quite a good teacher during a June
15th interview with the FBI Christensen
admitted to giving an Asian woman a ride
according to the complaint Christensen
said he believed he made a wrong turn
because the female became panicked he
then claimed he let her out of the car
during a search of Christensen's phone
they discovered he had visited a forum
in April called abduction 101
investigators began monitoring
Christensen's activities one
day after he was interviewed the day
before his arrest investigators recorded
Christiansen explaining how he had
kidnapped Jang took her back to his
apartment and held her against her will
Jang's family flew to Illinois after she
disappeared they kept their hope up
until the news came out that the
suspects are arrested in the FBI is
presumed that he probably won't be alive
Tina Chiu is acting as the family's
translator she says they won't leave
until Jang he's found the whole purpose
of on the trip was to bring him home so
I'm really hoping that they can find
their kid Jang came to the University of
Illinois Urbana in April as a visiting
scholar this fall she had planned to
join the school's doctoral program and
get her PhD